STATE CAPITOL BUILDING.
HE WILL DELIVER A VIRTUAL
ADDRESS THIS AFTERNOON.
CARLEY: ALL EYES ON THE CHAOS IN
AFGHANISTAN BUT BORDER OFFICIALS
SAY WE CAN’T FORGET THE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
ENCOUNTERS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER ARE AT A 21 YEAR HIGH.
JOINING US TO REACT AS CHIEF OF
THE BORDER PATROL AND REACTING
ICE DIRECTOR, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
THE NEW YORK POST SOME THE
CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS SAY ALL
EYES ARE ON AFGHANISTAN BUT THE
BORDER CRISIS HASN’T GONE AWAY,
LEAVE IT TO PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BORDER CRISIS
BY CREATING ANOTHER ONE IN
AFGHANISTAN, YET MAKE NO MISTAKE
THE STAMPEDE FROM THE SOUTH
TOWARDS THE MEXICAN BORDER
HASN’T SLOWED.
IT HAS ACCELERATED.
WE HAVE TWO CRISES FROM ONE
PRESIDENT, WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION?
>> WE HAVE A SITUATION IN 2021
WHERE THE MOST POWERFUL
GOVERNMENT ON EARTH CAN’T
PROTECT THE PEOPLE SERVING FOR
US ALONGSIDE US IN AFGHANISTAN
AND CAN’T SEEM TO USE THE
POLICIES THAT WERE WORKING TO
SECURE THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND
STOP A MONUMENTAL SURGE THAT
STARTED IN JANUARY AND IT STILL
CONTINUES TODAY.
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE GLOBE.
IF THEY MAKE IT TO THE CEMETERY
THEY ARE LIKELY TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES WHETHER ILLEGALLY
OR BEING LET IN AND RELEASED
BECAUSE OF POLICIES THAT WERE
INSTITUTED IN LATE JANUARY.
CARLEY: I WANT TO TO ASK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID PEOPLE FROM AFGHANISTAN
AREN’T FLYING DIRECTLY TO THE
UNITED STATES, IN THE US, IT
SOUNDS A LOT LIKE THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY.
WISE ONE OKAY BUT THE OTHER
REASONS?
>> THE RISKS ARE DIFFERENT, WHY
ARE WE NOT USING TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO THE US GOVERNMENT TO SECURE
THE BORDER, CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION OFFICERS AND ICE
OFFICIALS THE TOOLS TO PREVENT A
SURGE LIKE THIS, WHY WOULDN’T WE
DO THAT ON BEHALF OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, WHO IS BENEFITING,
THEY FEED OFF OF THIS CHAOS,
MORE DRUGS BEING SMUGGLED IN THE
UNITED STATES, MORE POWER TO
CORRUPT GOVERNMENTS AND IN THE
PIPELINE.
WHO IS BENEFITING FROM THIS?
NOT BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES OR ICE AGENTS OR
BORDER COMMUNITIES AND BORDER
HOSPITALS AND PEOPLE ON THAT
LINE, IT IS ALL MISERY FOR THEM
AND THOSE IN THE PIPELINE, THEY
ARE FLEEING VIOLENCE AND WILL
COME TO THE WORST NEIGHBORHOODS
IN THIS COUNTRY TO BE PREYED ON
BY THE VERY GANGS THAT ARE HERE.
JILLIAN: WE’VE SEEN DRUGS
POURING TO THE COUNTRY AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE WORRYING ABOUT
TERRORISM.
HOW EASY WOULD IT BE FOR A
TERRORIST OF HALF MEMBERS OF THE
NEXT CARTEL TO GET THEM INTO THE
COUNTRY.
>> NO REGARD FOR WHERE THEY MAKE
MONEY.
IT IS QUITE POSSIBLE A TERRORIST
NETWORK COULD USE EXISTING
PIPELINES TO FIND WAYS TO DO WAS
HARM.
THAT IS WHY THE APARTMENT WAS
CREATED.
THE BORDER PATROL WAS BEEFED UP
TO HAVE OPERATIONAL CONTROL SO
SOMEONE IN THE PIPELINE WE COULD
FIND THEM.
WE HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT.
>> BORDER PATROL AGENTS, MANY OF